>>> SO, AFTER 16 YEARS, THREE
GOLD MEDALS AND COUNTLESS OTHER
ACCOLADES, IT WAS A PRETTY
EMOTIONAL END FOR SNOWBOARDER
SHAUN WHITE AFTER MAKING THE
FINAL OLYMPIC RUN OF HIS CAREER.
>> GOSH, IT'S HARD TO DESCRIBE.
I MEAN, THERE WERE SO MANY
THOUGHTS GOING THROUGH MY HEAD
AND, YOU KNOW, IT'S A MIXTURE
OF, WOW, THIS IS SAD, I WON'T BE
DOING THIS ANYMORE, BUT THEN
AGAIN A RELIEF OF WOW, I'VE COME
THIS FAR AND I DESERVE, YOU
KNOW, THE REST AND, YOU KNOW,
THE ANXIETY AND THE FEAR AND ALL
THESE THINGS YOU HAVE TO DEAL
WITH AND COPE WITH DURING, YOU
KNOW, COMPETITION SEASON,
ESPECIALLY WITH SNOWBOARDING,
FLYING 20 FEET OUT OF A 20-FOOT
HALFPIPE, AND, YOU KNOW, THERE'S
CONSEQUENCES.
YOU'RE RIDING THIS FINE LINE OF
THAT DANGER, AND, YOU KNOW, I
REMEMBER SLIDING INTO THE BOTTOM
AND JUST THIS RUSH OF RELIEF,
AND THEN SEEING ALL MY
COMPETITORS KIND OF LINED UP,
YOU KNOW, WITH SOME REALLY KIND
WORDS TO SAY TO ME.
AND I JUST, LIKE, BROKE DOWN.
I COULDN'T HANDLE IT.
AND THE CROWD WAS CHEERING.
SUCH AN AMAZING SUPPORT FROM ALL
THE CHINESE, YOU KNOW, FANS AND
VOLUNTEERS AND JUST PEOPLE THAT
HAVE COME OUT OR WERE ALLOWED TO
COME AND WATCH.
IT WAS INCREDIBLE.
>> JOINING ME RIGHT NOW IS
RETIRED U.S. OLYMPIC SPEED
SKATER AND WINNER OF EIGHT
OLYMPIC GOLDS, APAL LOW ANTON
O
OHNO.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> WONDER TO FEEL SEE YOU.
>> YOU SAID GOOD-BYE TO THE
GAMES AFTER YOUR LENGTHY CAREER,
AND WE'VE HEARD SHAUN WHITE
REFLECT ON WHAT WAS GOING
THROUGH HIS MIND.
IF YOU'RE WATCHING, YOU KNOW,
HIS LAST RUN THAT EVENING, I WAS
WATCHING IT, AND I JUST SAW, YOU
KNOW, THE TEARS WELLING UP IN
HIS EYES, YOU KNOW, HE'S WAITING
FOR THE SCORE EVEN THOUGH HE
HADN'T COMPLETED THAT RUN LIKE
HE HAD WANTED AND PEOPLE WERE
HIGH-FIVING HIM.
WE HEARD HIM REFLECTING ON WHAT
HE WAS THINKING.
BUT AT THE TIME OF THAT LAST
RUN, WHAT WERE YOU IMAGINING HE
WAS GOING THROUGH?
>> LOOK, I THINK SHAUN IS A
COMPETITOR.
HE'S SHOWN OVER A LONG DURATION
BOTH HIS CONSISTENCY BUT ALSO
HIS LOVE FOR THE SPORT, I MEAN,
HIS LOVE FOR THE OLYMPIC PATH.
WHEN YOU WATCH THESE ATHLETES IN
THEIR FINAL KIND OF BOW IN THE
THING THAT GAVE THEM ALL THE
SIGNALS OF AFFIRMATION THAT THIS
IS YOUR PURPOSE, THIS IS WHY
YOU'RE HERE, IT'S A BEAUTIFUL
SIGHT AND IT'S ALSO SAD, RIGHT?
SO WHAT HAPPENS NOW IS THIS KIND
OF QUASI-GREAT DIVORCE WHERE
HE'S GOING TO BE TRANSITIONING
FROM ONE CHAPTER IN HIS LIFE
INTO THE NEXT, AND THAT
REINVENTION STAGE IS GOING TO BE
EXCITING.
I THINK SHAUN HAS A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF OPPORTUNITIES.
BUT NOT JUST SHAUN, ALL OF THESE
OLYMPIC ATHLETES.
SOME ARE DECIDING EITHER BY
CHOICE OR BY FORCE TO SAY WHAT'S
NEXT?
AND THAT GREAT DIVORCE IS VERY
VISCERAL AND REAL AS THEY COME
BACK HOME AFTER THE CLOSING
CEREMONIES.
>> YOU MADE THAT TRANSITION.
I MEAN, YOU'RE A MOTIVATIONAL
SPEAKER, AUTHOR, INVOLVED
YOURSELF IN A LOT OF
ENTREPRENEURIAL EFFORTS.
SO WHAT DOES THAT IS THAT
TRANSITION GOING TO BE LIKE, DO
YOU THINK, FOR HIM?
I'M SURE PEOPLE ARE COMING TO
HIM WITH IDEAS AS WELL.
BUT I GUESS IN THE END YOU HAVE
TO GOAT GO WITH WHAT YOUR HEART
SAYS OR HOW COMFORTABLE YOU ARE,
HOW EXHAUSTED MENTALLY AND
PHYSICALLY YOU MIGHT BE AT THE
TIME TOO.
>> LOOK, I THINK SHAUN'S GOING
TO HAVE A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
OPPORTUNITY POST HIS CAREER
HERE.
HE'S ALREADY SHOWN HIS INTEREST
IN SEEING HOW HE CAN ELEVATE HIS
BRAND AND ALSO GROW THE SPORT OF
SNOWBOARDING AND HALFPIPE.
HE'S DONE AN INCREDIBLE JOB AND
REALLY A TESTAMENT TO KIND OF
HIS FORESIGHT TO UNDERSTANDING
THAT THIS WILL ALL COME TO AN
END IN TERMS OF HIM STANDING ON
TOP OF THE PODIUM.
I THINK FOR A LOT OF THESE
ATHLETES IT'S A DEEPER
PSYCHOLOGICAL CONVERSATION THEY
HAVE WITH THEMSELVES.
WHAT ARE THEY GOOD AT?
WHAT IS THE MOST ALIGNED WITH
THEIR TRUE NORTH AND PURPOSE,
AND HOW CAN THEY CONTRIBUTE?
MANY ATHLETES HAVE PUT SCHOOL
OFF FAR LONG TIME AND MAYBE
THEY'RE ENTERING INTO THEIR LATE
20s, EARLY 30s WHERE THEY'RE
HAVING TO START BRAND-NEW.
THEY HAVE ALL THESE INCREDIBLE
ATTRIBUTES THAT HAVE BEEN LIFE
LESSONED EARNED THROUGHOUT THE
PATH OF THE OLYMPICS, AND NOW
APPLYING THEM TOWARDS THE NEXT
CHAPTER OF THEIR LIFE IS GOING
TO BE A CHALLENGE AND ALSO ONE
THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO EMBRACE.
SO AS ALL OF US HAVE FOR THE
PAST 24 MONTHS NEEDED AND
REQUIRED A CRITICAL PART OF US
EMBRACING CHANGE REGARDLESS OF
THESE CHAOTIC ENVIRONMENTS I
THINK WE LIVE IN.
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT AS WE
TRY TO SHOW UP ON A DAILY BASIS.
>> OTHERS WHO MIGHT BE THINKING
SOON ABOUT THAT TRANSITION, TOO,
WE HAVE SEEN NOW DURING THIS
OLYMPICS, PARTICULARLY IN SOME
OF THE AMERICAN ATHLETES, WE'VE
SEEN SENIORS, YOU KNOW, WHO
DOMINATE, I MEAN, SHAUN WHITE,
35, LINDSEY JACOB ELLIS, 36,
NICK BAUMGARTNER AT 40, AND THEY
BOTH CLINCHED GOLD LAST NIGHT.
IN THEIR STORIES JUST LIKE, YOU
KNOW, YOUR STORY, YOU ALL ARE
ARCHITECTS OF YOUR SPORTS, AND
THE SPORTS HAVE REACHED HEIGHTS
THAT NO ONE HAS EVER SEEN BEFORE
BECAUSE OF THE SACRIFICE OF
THESE ATHLETES WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS WHEN YOU
SEE THESE OLD CATS COMPETING
AGAINST THESE WHIPPERSNAPPERS
WHO ARE THE BENEFICIARIES OF A
SPORT THAT THEY HELPED
TRANSFORM?
>> WELL, I CAN RELATE TO ALL OF
THAT.
WHEN I MADE MY FIRST TEAM IN
2002 AND MY FINAL OLYMPIC TEAM
NEARLY ALMOST TEN YEARS LATER IN
2010, THERE WERE TEAM MEMBERS ON
MY TEAM WHO STARTED SPEED
SKATING BECAUSE THEY HAD WATCHED
MY FIRST EVER OLYMPIC GAMES.
I KNOW WHAT THAT PEOPLING IS
LIKE.
THE COOL PART IS THE TECHNOLOGY
THAT HAS TRANSFORMED SPORT IS
NOW ACCESSIBLE TO SO MANY, AND
SO MUCH LATER IN YOUR CAREER,
YOU CAN DO SO MUCH MORE WITH FAR
LESS.
YOU UNDERSTAND OVERTRAINING.
YOU UNDERSTAND RECOVERY.
OBVIOUSLY THE MIND IS STILL THE
GREATEST ASSET THAT WE HAVE.
AND LEARNING HOW TO KIND OF
COMPOUND THESE THINGS IN THE
SMALL INCREMENTS OVER TIME GIVE
THIS INCREDIBLE ABILITY OVER THE
LONG RUN TO BE YOUR ABSOLUTE
BEST.
SO I THINK WE'RE GOING TO SEE A
TREND OF OLDER ATHLETES,
TYPICALLY OLDER, PERFORMING AT
THE HIGHEST LEVELS.
WE SAW TOM BRADY AND WHAT HE'S
BEEN ABLE TO DO AS AN INCREDIBLE
EXAMPLE.
THIS IS GOING TO BE THE TREND
MOVING FORWARD.
I THINK ATHLETES' CAREERS ARE
GOING TO BE EXTENDED, WHICH IS
GREAT, WHICH HOPELY GIVES THEM
MORE TIME TO PREPARE FOR WHEN
THEY HAVE TO HANG UP THOSE
SKATES, SO TO SPEAK, AND FIGURE
OUT HOW TO CONTRIBUTE TO OUR
COMMUNITIES AND SOCIETY AT
LARGE.
>> SO GREAT.
FROM THOSE HIGH POINTS TO A REAL
LOW POINT, THE 15-YEAR-OLD
RUSSIAN SKATER, KAMILA VALIYEVA,
THE COURT OF ARBITRATION WILL
HAVE A HEARING TOMORROW AFTER
SHE TESTED POSITIVE FOR A HEART
DRUG BACK IN DECEMBER THAT MIGHT
ASSIST IN HER STAMINA.
SO WHAT IS THE.
MESSAGE NOW BEING SENT IF SHE IS
ALLOWED TO CONTINUE TO COMPETE
IN BEIJING, EVEN IF SHE WAS
SURREPTITIOUSLY GIVEN THIS DRUG?
>> SO, I DON'T KNOW THE DETAILS
AROUND, YOU KNOW, THE AMOUNTS,
WHAT TYPE -- ARE THESE TRACE
AMOUNTS, IS THIS SOMETHING THAT
WAS MUCH MORE INTENTIONAL?
IT'S VERY HARD.
THE WORLD ANTI-DOPING
ASSOCIATION AND ALL THESE
GOVERNING BODIES, IT'S THEIR JOB
TO PROVIDE THE MOST EQUAL AND
LEVEL LG PLAYING FIELD.
AT 15, HER PERFORMANCE WAS
INCREDIBLE.
IT'S TOUGH IN A BEAUTIFUL SPORT
LIKE FIGURE SKATING.
HOPEFULLY, WE CAN FIGURE OUT THE
BEST WAY MOVING FORWARD, BUT,
AGAIN RULES ARE THERE, WE NEED
OUR GUARDRAILS, AND ATHLETES,
REGARDLESS OF WHERE THEY'RE
TRAINING AND COMPETING,
REGARDLESS OF THOSE CULTURE
ENVIRONMENTS, NEED TO MAKE SURE
THEY'RE HAVING THAT SAME TIME OF
MENTALITY AND SAME SYSTEM.
THAT'S THE ONLY WAY THE OLYMPICS
CAN KIND OF MAINTAIN THIS.
BY THE WAY, WE LOOK AT THE
OLYMPICS AS THE ONE SOURCE OF
BEING THE PLACE WHERE WE CAN
ACTUALLY CORRAL AROUND AND IS A
FUNDAMENTAL PLAYING GROUND.
SO IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
STAY ON TOP OF THESE THINGS AND
MAKE SURE IT IS FAIR, IT IS
CLEAN, AND THESE ATHLETES ARE
GIVING THEIR BEST EVERY SINGLE
TIME WE SEE THEM.
>> THE GREATEST PEACETIME EVENT
EPITOMIZING ALL THE ABILITIES
AND STRENGTHS OF HUMAN BEINGS.
APOLO ANTON OHNO, THANKS FOR